la crise sanitaire et économique
entraînera tel un nombre record de
faillites d'entreprises en 2020 oui
selon les économistes de l'assureur
crédit coface qui prévoit la faillite de
plus de 58 milles société cette année
des entreprises qui ferment à cause
d'une crise ce n'est pas nouveau
souvenez vous en 2008 tant que je vais
vous dire c'est que ça va dégager durant
des entreprises là il va avant de tomber
comme des rougeurs automne 2008 la
france est touchée de plein fouet par la
crise économique venue des états unis
des sociétés voient leur activité se
réduire drastiquement son arrêt
apparemment que l'activité des tpe aux
grandes entreprises de la construction
et l'automobile
la crise économique n'épargne personne
certaines entreprises sont plus touchées
que d'autres compagnies plus de 55000 au
total en 2008 selon la coface chemin
quand il veut dire maintien comme le et
bat tout le boulot je vais ou merde
parmi ces entreprises en difficulté la
camif particuliers une filiale
spécialisée dans la vente par
correspondance en octobre 2008 cette
société de 780 salariés et placée en
liquidation judiciaire ce qui se passe
du magasin est mal au coeur conséquence
de cette liquidation judiciaire son
transporteur met la clé sous la porte
quelques mois plus tard une entreprise
qui ferme c'est toute une chaîne qui
s'en trouve impactée c'est l'effet
domino de la crise économique
la camif a représenté jusqu'à 40 pour
son activité dur at one elle
représentait environ encore un quart du
chiffre d'affaires
donc ça a forcément des conséquences
extrêmement importante 2009 année noire
pour l'économie française
la situation se dégrade les entreprises
défaillantes
c'est à dire en dépôt de bilan ou en
redressement judiciaire augmentent leur
nombre s'élève à 62 1344 soit sept mille
trois cents de plus que l'année
précédente
exemple à montpellier dans l'hérault en
janvier 2008 on a enregistré à peu près
30% d'augmentation de dépôt de bilan
entre redressement judiciaire et
liquidation judiciaire et cette tendance
sur début février se confirmerait il
faut attendre 2010 pour que le nombre de
familles commencent à diminuer cette
année là 59140 quatre entreprises ont
déposé le bilan
ces deux mille sept cents de moins que
l'année précédente l'activité reprend
lentement en france
j'ai connu du chômage partiel entre 2
c'est toujours récupérer maintenant on
est revenue à du travail constante
après 2010 le nombre de dépôts de bilan
stagne ce n'est qu'à partir de 2016
qu'il baisse vraiment en 2018
il diminue encore jusqu'à atteindre 50
1643 en 2019
avec la crise du coït 19 il devrait
considérablement augmenter en 2020 selon
des économistes de coface
[Musique]